yolande aujourd'hui se trouve non pas
sur des voies de lèche bottes mais sur
chim bottes quand la bêtise va trop loin
ni les enfants bonjour jeune chimpanzé
dit bonjour aux gens
d'accord cela n'a aucun sens tu es un
simple chapeau est connu mais j'ai pas
chaque fois et pourquoi sont ils ces
tueries la voix cassée je suis reposé
vous avez pour commencer tu vas te
détendre ou plutôt tu vas me détendre
c'est exact oui il est pas les passer
con que ça fait moi du bien alors faire
on ferme les yeux vous êtes fait parler
ça fait mal avec ses mains d'accord bon
si nous dit nous comment ça se passe
entre toi et vie c'est plutôt amitié ou
amour dont et parlons-en aller alors là
c'est toi c'est toi là c'est la seiva
synovate la faute sur les autres ok je
te trouve très mignon c'est vrai je suis
sincère il est content regarder et
trésor ni eau et b as à le faire voguer
voilà j'ai jamais vu de phrases aussi
longues de ma vie je pense que ça
pourrait aller plus loin entre nous
contre la terreur scandale pour l'autre
bah ça n'a aucun sens japon est ce que
c'est notre amour qui trop fou c'est toi
à l'ordinateur je sais que c'est dur à
battre mais tu n'es qu'un [ __ ] match
opposait qui en fait est en paix ses
allées convaincu l'un ok choix
d'ordinateurs dont j'ai mis six chiens
affamés forte la plus garce gardel chat
commence à bien faire howell et gratuite
j'ai de sérieux problèmes charest doit
bien défini je suis quelqu'un
d'ordinaire copies écoulées à bercy
c'était pas 18 34 qui a écrit ça à chaud
c'est très gentil stéphanie battant tu
lâches ton pc tu vas travailler et tu
veux la sphère ma vidéo
une économie non j'ai juste des
problèmes tu vois ça c'est toi ça c'est
toi chante i tout ce temps là par les
toits pour ces cas toi et aux le mode il
tourne pas autour de toi je sais plus
quoi faire
mais nous on va demander conseil évite
aux puncheurs poser très bizarre avec
moi non je suis ta binard mari mais je
parle patois arrêter de penser qu'à vous
[ __ ] dès qu il n'y a qu'une personne
qui peut me comprendre bois et moi s'il
te plaît ton ami cher pour ses membres
on a fait du mal tu veux une machine
mais moi je suis un humain et je
coordonnées de transférer 1 milliards de
dollars du complexe vers le mien
il y avait déjà un beau pas la question
et ensuite il ya vraiment un mec qu'un
internaute qui croyais que ça allait
marcher quel est le voc
oui les cinq ans sa voix car moi dire
quelque chose on va maintenant repartir
sur de bonnes bases
je te bases beaucoup mais pas contre un
retour n'est pas clean machine
ok pour nous mais j'ai dit ok je suis
une machine ne fait que tuer aucune
maîtrise mais ferme ta gueule plus tard
j'adore les licornes pour les manger
bien compliqué beaucoup mais avec
beaucoup nous oui c'est comme un peu
bizarre bonjour bonjour je suis dame est
une fille mais avec mes copains et la
famille one could have you ou la
nouvelle c'est vrai par la main
d'accord donc à perdre fc copa traîne
sur ce site qui est sur youtube heures
préféré satellite youtuber préféré à gré
des avc gdf ont été votées pour se
battre le gras sous les yeux et ou non
mais moi c'est les abonnés de squeeze
croqua d'arqués est en union hummer
préférées d'accord ça parce qu'avant
d'agressif qui est tu meurs favori
hausse avait à l'oeil ou tu veux c'est
plus tard que d'en traduire cette vidéo
que je tombe malade c'est beau parce
qu'on s'en fout on allait demander à
l'ue avant pas compris le principe du
site
c'est des gens comme moi qui te réponds
10,3 au message filmé au nom c'est
quelqu'un qui est complexe et qui
revient à parler un chimpanzé virtuel
pour le plus complet que ces noms alors
écoute lisa ne doit pas complexés sur
quoi que ce soit dit se poser des
questions surtout physique un vtt à
l'adolescence il pousse c'est normal
effet c'est pareil tout va bien et aucun
problème et si ça pousse pas tout va
quand même bien ok tu aimerais tu étais
d'accord donc tu as bien et était
apparemment où j'ai mûri font comme nous
avec leur territoire
allez tu étais avec leurs petits pois
poil bavard et chacun son style
moi j'avoue j'aime bien les tt comme moi
pas trop poilus bah moi ya pas de poils
autour ils sont biens neufs rouge oui
voilà j'en retiens pas tes vidéos sur un
chien bonne chez soi c'est aux appuie
ces cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude
eh ben c'est toujours aussi des bidasses
société en plus dira parfois par contre
que les conversations se croient ça
donne un truc vraiment cool ou quad vtt
poilus par exemple mais ça va regarder
en s'entraidant une prochaine vidéo
party ou bien tu retournes by sa
à